and good evening to you thanks for
joining us at six i'm brian loftis i'm
denise valdez the clark county
firefighter is accused of also trying to
work as a pimp the 8 news now i-team has
obtained details at the center of what
is now a criminal case vanessa murphy is
here with that story
police say trayvion evans seemed to
think he was talking to a sex worker but
instead she was an undercover officer by
the way the arrest report has graphic
language throughout which we can't say
on television now evans faces a felony
charge for pandering and he could lose
his job as a firefighter
it's just another challenge with being a
major tourist destination the eight news
now i-team was given exclusive access to
an undercover operation to bust pimps on
memorial day weekend fast forward to
february 4 during a similar operation on
the las vegas strip metro police say one
of the suspected pimps they arrested is
also a clark county firefighter
according to this arrest report obtained
by the i-team trayvion evans began
talking with a woman who said she was a
working girl trying to hustle police say
he asked if she'd work for him promised
to make her money and told her how much
to charge for sex acts his fee 500 a
night evans also instructed her how to
steal from clients a term commonly known
as a trick role according to the arrest
report what evans didn't know was that
woman is an undercover officer for
metro's vice unit police say evans knew
the lingo typically used by prostitutes
and pimps and he was in an area which
sources tell the eye team is frequented
for sex work the arrest report states
evans and the undercover officer
connected at planet hollywood according
to a spokeswoman for clark county evans
a firefighter since 2020 is now on
unpaid leave from the clark county fire
department pending the outcome of his
case
the i-team confirmed evans also worked
as a clark county school district bus
driver from 2016 to 2018 i asked which
routes he drove and i was told that
information is unavailable